اذا وصل الجنيه المصري تراجعه مسجلا ادى
مستوياته على الاطلاق امام الدولار وتجاوز
سعر الدولار مستوى 30 جنيه خلال تداولات
هذا اليوم تتعرض العمله المصريه للضغوط مع
رفع المركز المصري لاسعار الفائده مؤخرا
وسماحه بهبوط العمله اضافه الى طرح اكبر
مصرفين في البلاد شهادات ادخار بمعدلات
فائده قياسيه ياتي هذا التهاوي وسط
التصاعدي ازمه شحه الدولار في مصر
واستمرار تداعيتها على حركه الاستيراد
اذا تجاوز تراجع الجنيه المصري امام
الدولار الثلاثين جنيها واربعين قرشا في
هذه اللحظات وهو متراجع بنحو العشره في
المئه وقد ايضا يسجل تراجع في هذه اللحظات
ما يقارب الجنيهين والثمانين قرشا ليضيف
الى خسائر اليوم نحو الثلاثه جنيهات وهو
منخفض بهذه النسبه وفقا لارقام البنك
المركزي وهو اكبر تحرك له في يوم واحد منذ
اكتوبر عندما سمح له بالتراجع الحاد في
اخر مره مع الاعلانه حزمه التمويل جديده
مع صندوق النقد الدولي وقد تراجع الجنيه
خلال عام كما تشاهدون نحو 95 في المئه اي
نوع نحو الضعف خلال عام واحد
كذلك قال البنك المركزي المصري ان معدل
التضخم الاثاسي ارتفع شهر الماضي النحو 24
ونصف في المئه على اساس سنوي يعذر ارتفاع
تضخم الى عوامل من بينها القيود الحكوميه
على الواردات وتدهور سعر صرف الجنيه مقابل
العملات الرئيسيه وعلى راسها الدولار
الامريكي وكاله الحكومه المصريه قررت
اخيرا تخفيض الانفاق غير الضروري حتى
نهايه السنه الماليه الحاليه لدعم
احتياطيات البلاد من النقد الاجنبيه ومن
جهه قدر تقرير للخبراء صندوق النقد الدولي
ان مصر التزمت بمجموعه من الاصلاحات
النقديه والماليه من بينها السماح بمرونه
الاكبر في سعر الصرف ودور اوسع للقطاع
الخاص
موضوعنا الرئيسي بشان الهبوط القياسي
للجنيه المصري ومعنا من القاهره الخبير
الاقتصادي ممدوح الولي نرحب بك سيد ممدوح
اذا يعني تراجع الدولار بشكل اتراجع
الجنيه امام الدولار بشكل كبير وواضح وهو
الاكبر تاريخيا وبنحو الثلاثين جنيه مقابل
الدولار هناك لا شك عده اسباب نعلمها لكن
هل من توضيح اكبر
يعني اسباب متعدده ولكنها واضحه
فسببت همم مساله تثبيت سعر الصرف لثلاث
سنوات وعدم تحريكها حتى مارس الماضي
وعندما تحركت تحرك البنك المركزي بالنسبه
16% فقط ولم يكن هذا كافيا وظل البنك
المركزي يحرك سعر صرف بشكل بطيء حتى وصلنا
الى اواخر اكتوبر الماضي قام البنك
المركزي ايضا بتحريك سعر 16% فقط بينما
كان السوق السوداء الذي نشا منذ فبراير
الماضي
يزيد عن سعر البنك المركزي بشكل كبير لكن
البنك المركزي ظل اقل من السعر السوق
السوداء وكذلك لم يكن يلبي طلبات
المستوردين وكذلك كانت هناك سلعه عن
متراكمه في الموانئ من شهر فبراير الماضي
لم يق بمساله تمويلها وبالتالي ظلت
المشكله قائمه حتى اضطر البنك المركزي في
اوائل العام الحالي ان يقوم بتحريك ايضا
ولكنه ايضا لم يكن كافيا حيث كان السعر
بالسوق السوداء
يزيد عنه ايضا وبالتالي يعني لجا اليوم
الى ان يقترب كثيرا من سعر السوق الامريكي
همم التوقعات والتحليلات همم الى سعر
الجنيه في المستقبل القريب هل سيشهد اخر
يعني اتوقع ذلك لانه يعني في التجارب
السابقه لسعر الصرف في مصر قام محافظ
البنك المركزي فاروق العقده في سنه 2004
بالقفز على سعر السوق السوداء اي انه لابد
ان يتخطاها حتى يعود بسحب السعر بالوراء
قليلا بالتدريج قام بنفس الامر
المحافظ السابق في 2016 في نوفمبر 2016
حيث قام طارق
على السعر بالسوق السوداء الذي تخطى وقتها
ال 18 جنيها ثم سحبه الى الوراء بالتدريج
ونحن نحتاج الى يعني هذه المره بنفس
السيناريو ان يتم القفز على سعر السوق
السوداء بالمقابل او بالتوازي لابد ان
يستجيب البنك المركزي بشكل سريع للاستجابه
لاخراج السلع الموجوده في هذه المواد
المحافظين البنوك المركزيه في عام 2016
و17 الان ما هي الخطوه التي قد ايضا تريح
همم او همم تساعد على خفض معدل مستوى
انخفاض الجنيه امام الدولار ما هي الادوات
الماليه المتاحه لدى البنك المركزي ووزاره
الماليه
للاسف الادوات هذه المره
عوامل ساعدت على التغلب على مساله السوق
السوداء كان لدينا القروض الخارجيه حوالي
12 مليار بالتوازي مع 12 مليار من الصندوق
كان هناك طرح للسندات بدات بالنصف الاول
من عام 2017 كان هناك الاموال الساخنه
التي جاءت سريعا لمصر في النصف الاول في
عام 2017 نحن هذه المره ليس امامنا سوى
عامل وحيد وهو ال14 مليار التي ستلد لمصر
بالجوار قرض الصندوق من مؤسسات وبنوج
دوليه لكنها ليست قرود كلها كما قال
الصندوق ولكن غاليتها ستكون بيع لاصول في
شركات مصريه وبالتالي نحن نحتاج الى وقت
حتى يتم استقرار سعر صرف في المره السابقه
في عام 2016 استمر الامر سته شهور حتى تم
التغلب على السوق السوداء وبالتالي نحن في
احتياج الى مثل هذا هذه المده هذه المره
وقد يكون الامر اكثر من ذلك لان المشكله
الان اصعب مما كانت عليه في 2016 وبالتالي
الموارد ما زالت محدوده التحويلات تحتاج
الى ثقه وانتهاء للسوق السوداء حتى تعود
الى القنوات الرسميه الصادرات ما زالت
تحتاج الى دفعه والى توافر بوستلزمات
الانتاج حتى تقوم الشركات بالانتاج بنفس
السائقه وبالتالي الامر اصعب مما كان عليه
في 2016 شكرا جزيلا لك من القاهره ممدوح
الوليه الخبير الاقتصادي